[MUSIC]
Neil, welcome to the GSB.
>> Thank you for having me here.
>> Really excited to have you here today
as our first guest for speaker series.
So, as Mario mentioned
in the introduction,
you have had an incredible career,
internationally.
And over the next 40 minutes we will want
to talk about your personal journey,
both as an entrepreneur
as well as an investor.
And we would love to hear
about some of the huge and
exciting market in China today.
We'll also going to have the last 20
minutes for questions from the audience.
>> Get us started.
You grew up in China and
in 1989 you came to the U.S. Initially for
a PhD program in math and you made
a decision to do an MBA a year after that.
Very validating for
all the MBAs here to hear.
>> That's how we call it MPPM.
I was telling people this is like MBA and,
often time, need a lot of explanations.
Definitely.
And you chose to go into banking
straight after your MBA.
So I'm going to take us to the year 1999,
at this point you've been in banking for
eight years.
You're running China capital markets for
Deutsche Bank, and
you're doing really well in your career.
But at this point you choose to
make two pretty big decisions.
One, you leave banking to
start your own business.
And two,
you decided to move back to China.
Tell us more about your
thoughts behind that decision.
>> I think I can talk a little
bit sort of the thoughts
applied to my decision to go
back to China star sea trip.
I think as someone who left China
after four years of college,
he always want to do some scene for
China or around China.
Obviously upon graduation from Chang Tong,
probably the best choice for
me at that time is go to U.S. and study.
But, while I was in New York I
always thinking, can I do something?
Can I leverage my China experience,
or background?
So, 1992, 1994, there's an opportunity
you can go back to China and be part of
the so called capital markets efforts.
Many students who study in the US or
work in the U.S. before, end up joining
those Asian branch of big investment bank.
And I'm part of them.
And you get very excited, because when
you back you see how China has changed
from the 1980s against
the time when I left China.
So you really feel like there's
a lot of things you can do.
But back in 1994, 1995 most of the so
called economic reform around big
enterprises, especially SOE's.
What really actually have changed
is toward the end of 1990,
you know the 1990's,
when private enterprises
come to become one of the major force
in the whole economic development.
And so people like myself when
I first working in it you know?
In the events and banking world in China,
my major customers are you know,
the Chinese corporates.
And the first one knocked at door at
this [INAUDIBLE] at the Bank of China.
And then you starting to find that there
are opportunity to do financings for
private companies.
And because of that, you're thinking
about whether you can be part of them.
At that time,
entrepreneurship was not a popular word.
And people like myself say,
I don't have much opportunity to do that,
because you need a very
large amount of capital.
I mean, the first batch of Chinese
private enterprises typically are in
the area like manufacturings,
transfer from the.
The so-called county
enterprise before all real
estate developers who make
the first their goal.
Then venture into other areas.
But for myself who has not,
do not have a lot of capital,
there's not much really I can do.
Until Internet come to play.
And I have the thank U.S.
for giving me the inspiration.
I came to Silicon Valley very often,
because I have a lot of classmates who
are working in different tech firms here.
>From 1998 all the way to 2000, each
time when I came, I noticed big changes.
Because many of those who work at Oracle,
SAP, IBM,
before have switched to inside jobs.
And when I'm walking through you know
all those on drive through 101, you see
the big billboard change from advertising
of big companies to Internet companies.
So you see the Internet is really
changing how people live and
work here in U.S.
And naturally, you will think,
well if this going to be the case in US,
it should happen in China.
So, I have to say the first batch
of internet entrepreneur in China,
whether it's Bioduel,
or Tenson, or C-trip,
will get inspired because these
successful models in the U.S., and
we know we can do similarly like how U.S.
counterparts.
Basically not a lot of capital sell, but
you can use venture capital to
help you to grow your business.
So my first venture as Sea Trip,
is exactly followed that route.
It's been doin.g very good and
if experience could
change the chow industry so
much in U.S. where on in China.
So that's how I started Sea Trip in 1999.
Frankly, it's a very difficult decision.
If I'm a software engineer,
it's probably a natural extension
of my previous professions.
I was a banker, right?
A banker provides advice to
the corporates in the merger and
acquisitions, debt financings, IPOs.
And I changed my role completely
to something very, very new to me.
And it was a very big venture for me.
And the only thing I'm comfortable is
that, I know if I'm not successful.
I can always go back,
because if Deutsche Bank does not hire me,
there's someone else going to hire me.
Look back,
is actually not very good mentality.
Because when you do
entrepreneurship you better be so
determined that you will
make it successful.
Not just to hoping that one
day you're going to go back.
You should not leave yourself
any other possibilities.
But, that's how [LAUGH] I started.
I do know I have possibilities.
If I can be successful, and
I clear understand that there's
a good chance that I might not.
I can go back, and
maybe another bank going to hire me.
But, when I really get involved
with It startup, you dont' have
time to think about anything, because you
want to survive and you want to do well.
And everyday you're just so
heavily engaged with
your surviving efforts.
Indeed, I would say the first two years
you try to find your business model.
You work day and night.
You don't have time to even think
about where's my, as alternatives.
You don't, yeah, I actually,
just tell you guys a little story.
When I resigned from Deutsch Bank,
my boss,
the head of Asia capital markets say,
Neil, you should stay four more months.
I say why four more months?
Because euro is just
created around that time.
And the euro was introduced
as a major currency.
I was a fixed income banker, and
I had been covered minister of
finance of China for many years.
And minister of finance had a plan
to go to euro, Europe too, actually.
Our launch is first Europe bank.
So my boss tell me, look, you haven't
covered the costs for so many years.
It's your pride to actually
launch a Euro bank for
the Minister of Finance and
this is your country.
You would be so proud of doing that.
Just wait for four months.
And I check with my [INAUDIBLE] and
they say you can't wait for four months.
Entrepreneurship is about speed.
Another four months you
don't know what can happen.
So I decide to quit in November, December
instead of wait until that spring in 2000.
Interestingly, I never
requite that decision because
the Europe bond was not launch until yet
to solve [INAUDIBLE].
Europe will not doing well
as you guys all know, right?
And the Europe coming down and
the ministry finance, no,
no I don't want to do it.
So they wait until 2002 or
2003 to actually launch the Euro bank.
So I go back to tell my boss later become
an independent director of C-Trip.
I say look, if I wait for four months, I'm
going to wait for another ten months, and
maybe two years and
there will never be a C-Trip.
So if you like to do something,
if you really feel like there's
something calling you inside,
you better do it, right away.
And that's about,
all about entrepreneurship.
>> So, you said that you could always go
back to banking if you weren't doing well.
Well, you were doing very well at C-trip,
you started in 1999.
And in just four years,
before the Euro bank was launched,
you brought it public, listed on NASDAQ.
And whats amazing is it's not
even the only company you found
a successful in that period.
In 2002 you found a Home Inns, now one
of the largest hotel chains in China.
We're in more than 300 cities,
close to 3,000 hotel chains.
And also four years listed on NASDAQ,
how do you do it?
What do you think its contributed
to your success as entrepreneur?
>> I think it's very important that
once you get into the business
you are able to really
understand the sector very well.
Instead of just looking
at your own business,
and say, I'm doing my daily execution.
So at a sea trip, it's really a very
eye opening opportunity for me, for
the whole hospitality industry.
You realize,
oh, the Chinese travel agencies are so
backwards in terms of their IT systems.
And there's so much middle man involved in
bringing a customer whether it's business
or leisure to the ultimate destinations.
There's so much you can do.
Obviously as a company
you can't just one issue.
But you do get to know a lot
about the whole industry.
One thing which we noticed, when I
walked in a sea trip is all upstream,
so called in the hotel industry itself
is again, very, very under developed.
For example, there's many so
called business hotel or
economy hotel chains in the US,
but in China back in 2002 and
2003 there's almost none.
And it's actually shocking
to me that there's no
such hotel which catering
to a specific needs.
And when we launch [INAUDIBLE] initially,
I was a little bit concerned
how big our company could be.
Because each hotel is small,
100 room, 150 rooms,
and how big a company this could become,
or whether China's ready.
But, again, I got inspiration from U.S.,
I remember I was in
Dallas visiting a few travel
service company because that was
the hub of many U.S.
travel service companies.
And I arrive at the airport,
I rent a car, drive from the airport
all the way to downtown.
It was like night time around 9 pm,
whatever.
And during that 20 to 30 minutes drive,
I observed there's about 15 different
names of budget hotels or
economy hotel chain.
>From Red Roof, all the way to Motel 6,
whatever, and the total number
of hotels I counted around 25.
So, from Dallas,
from Suburban airport to the city, you
can have 25 hotels, so I say, well, market
size is not a problem for China now.
[LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH]
>> That indeed,
I never imagine we can have
3,000 hotels In China.
Of by all means, this all created by our
efforts and by many of our competitors,
and the market is definitely there and
the demand is so big.
And we just need to create a good
product to cater to the users.
>> To meet quite a few transitions
going from a PhD to a MBA and
then banking to entrepreneurship.
In 2005, you make yet
another big decision going from
being an entrepreneur to becoming
the entrepreneur behind entrepreneurs.
And what's really interesting is you
could have chosen to start your own fun,
which I'm sure you have
plenty of resources to do.
But instead, you decided to be
a franchise with Sequioa Capital
was really well established
American brand.
What was some of this considerations
behind bringing this global
brand to China?
>> Well, I think, first of all,
if you look at my career, from PhD proven.
I never got a PhD to MBAs, or not MBAs,
MPPMs and to banking etc,, I don't
think we had many choices back then.
And this is something which you guys
compared with us, you guys are so lucky.
I'm talk about especially those
public students from China ,because
when I arrive in New York, I don't think I
can get into business school right away.
And again, of the business school,
you don't have many choices either.
And oftentimes, you never go into
internship or prior working experience,
so can tell you what's your best fit for
you.
But what actually drives me to make
those choices is that you
see the great opportunity.
And also, you go with the whole track.
In the last 20, 30 the big trend
is that you think that China
is going to become a global economy,
a powerhouse.
And if you believe in that and
in a poker term you call it,
if you are owing China you
are largely doing well.
And I guess that's probably going to be
the case for the next ten or 20 years.
If you, so called, can do or
if you belong in China, or
even more so, all-in China,
you are likely to do well.
And coming back to doing venture capital,
I always think that probably
the best before me after spending
seven years at the bank,
and then another six years.
As an entrepreneur is getting to
investment field because you can
leverage your experience both as
a financier as well as an entrepreneur.
So that's something which I
think public fit me very well.
Clearly I never planned that I never
get in the bank and say one day I do
entrepreneurship and then I can best
fit myself as a venture capitalist.
I never do that.
Say I'm on a sea trip I only want to
survive and make sea trip a great company.
Never think that okay,
this [INAUDIBLE] can position
myself be a good venture
capitalist sometime down the road.
Now, I can do for myself.
Indeed, I make some personal
investment while at sea trip and
some of those are very successful
like folks media, E-House.
But I was thinking how I can so
the best leverage,
in my experience, at the same time
can really make an investment and
have a big impact on the whole
so-called new economy.
You can set up, for myself but,
I think it's can be grow,
public not as fast compared with
setting up something with Sequoia.
And also, I feel like I really
want to learn from what
a firm like Sequoia has been
accumulating in the last 40 years.
In Silicon Valley, there's a many firms
has been active in the investment space,
but Sequoia has been,
obviously, the longest, and
still probably the best or
I will say at least one of the best.
So, I was very intrigued how they can do
that, one generation after the other.
So, three,
to raise money to make investment is
probably not the most difficult thing.
But, so China seems how to
make a sustainable business?
To me, I think Sequoia,
China is just like another venture.
If you want to make one or
two good investments, that's an easy job.
But how you can build a team?
And how to make a sensible business?
Just like what i did at sea trip I think
that's a very very different thing.
And today look back, after ten years,
I'm very happy the choice i made.
Because on our ten year anniversary,
we have allowed this entrepreneur,
which becomes Sequoia portfolio of CEOs.
But more importantly, from ten years ago,
a three person, four person team,
today we have 12 partners, and
we have cover some of the most important
set us in China and become investors
in many of the leading companies.
And that's something which is probably
difficult to achieve just with one man's
efforts or with friends.
>> So on that topic,
Sequoia capital in China, for
the last ten years,
has a phenomenal track record.
It pretty much put money in all of
China's biggest unicorns, Alibaba,
JD.com, Vipshop,
people call you Trainus Midas.
You turn stone to gold.
What do you think makes you so successful
as an investor, especially in China?
What's your secret sauce?
>> Well I think this venture
capitol investment is,
as a professional always has a regret.
Clearly you have lot of very
successful companies but
obviously we also have a lot of regret and
frankly mistakes.
And the good thing is you
learn from your mistakes and
then you try to improve every year.
The other thing very important is
when you look at the Sequoia US,
they have 48 high street.
They have long list of success.
Oracle, Cisco, Apple and
then Google, et cetera.
And one of reason behind that is they
able to capture all the major trend.
And they're able to say no to some trend
which turned out to be
just pure illusions and
that I think is probably
the most important factors
behind the success of firms like Sequoia.
And see, for us in China,
if there's any kind of
so-called success for us,
then that's, I think,
we have been really taking
the major trend right.
I remember back seven years ago, we have
decided that we should spend enough time,
and put enough investment
into e-commerce area.
We do have a view that e-commerce will
become very, very important in China.
Probably even more important,
compared with retail space in the US.
So we amassed probably around
15 e-commerce company in China.
Some of those are not successful,
but we did capture the top
five to six very successful
e-commerce in China.
Same for O to O.
Offline to online is not a big space
in the US, but it was a big space,
and continued to be a very
important space for China.
We think this is a very important area for
us.
And we did a lot of research back four or
five years ago.
We invest probably around
again 12 to 15 company.
And we happened to capture
the very top four companies,
from Mai Twan to Jan Ping
to Otama to Da Ta.
And that's the way I think probably
good firms should make investments.
You actually have a view on the market,
and
hopefully a little bit earlier
than most other people.
And you put big emphasize on the sectors,
and
making multiple investments
in that sectors.
And this is same for US.
If you look at Sequoia,
back in 40 years ago,
they pay big attention
to summer conductors.
And then summer conductor
leads to personal computer.
And they again, invest multiple
company in personal computer.
And then to software companies.
And then,
where internet comes into the major scene,
they invest multiple internet companies.
And then going to mobile internet.
That is the way I think a good
investor should follow.
The I'm about it.
There always something which you will
missed, because of judgement on person,
or judgement on particular business model,
but that's okay.
You always will make mistake, but
as long as you capture all the major
trends, you'll be doing very, very fine.
And sometimes you are including
to say no to some sectors.
I remember seven,
eight years ago is a buzz
word both here in the US as
well as in China and luckily,
our US partners as well as our China
partners decided this is not a big area.
Fundamentally it's not easy to create
large market caps by investing
venture capital or
even private equities into the sectors.
Indeed, after ten years
anyone can remember
like what are the top multi-billion
dollar company of the space?
Nothing, all right.
And avoid those sort of pitfalls is
again very, very important, because.
There are certain firms spend one third
of their time and money into the space.
And they end up finding that
there is not much there.
I think it's probably
the most important efforts.
And, you know, I'm and judgemental costs.
Coming down to companies,
you always will make mistakes.
I remember, when we look at
the video space back nine years ago.
We liked the space.
And we actually put a lot of effort on it.
And U.S. so far has invested in YouTube,
very successful.
We picked the number three player in the
space, and it's just a small game for us.
And these things will happen all the time,
because you may not be,
do all right, for
judging a particular entrepreneur.
In that particular case,
the companies found that it was
not very good at marketing, and
happen to be that marketing is the key
efforts for a video sharing companies.
And sometimes you get lucky,
like in our case VIP shop, or JD, or
you know recent case like a made.
But the big trend is a lot more
important to calling right
on one particular company.
>> So what are doing on some of
these major trends, going forward?
What excites you about China today?
>> I think every couple of year there
always some technology breakthroughs.
And the last five years in the U.S., the
big scene is big data star enterprises.
And is not a big scene in China as yet.
But I think it's becoming
increasing important.
In fact, I was think the returnees
from this part of world is
very free from Silicon Valley.
Might have a better role to play in China.
If you talk about big data and
software enterprises.
China, in this time, is like U.S.,
five, six years ago.
Where you come down to enterprises
softwares, sans enterprises and big datas.
So I think this is actually a great
opportunity and just like 1999,
there's many big internet companies U.S.
being founded.
China, there's very few areas
that have been covered, and
this is very much comparable.
And when you come down to, for
the attorneys to go back
to a founding company.
I think this is actually a very good area.
Because if you talk about consumer
Internet, you may not be able to
compete successfully against so
called the local guy.
Because in the consumer Internet space,
the culture factor is so heavy.
You have to understand
your user very well.
If you work in the U.S.
for too long you may not do that.
If you look at it like Charleston,
and you feel like Robin Lee.
When they go back to China,
they have a very long working
experience here in the U.S..
They're not like an early employer or
an early employer of Google to go
back to funding Chinese companies.
But in the enterprise area, the technology
component is more important.
So people work here for
many years in that space,
could actually play a very important role,
in shaping up the space in China.
So I think this is definitely
a very important area.
The other important area is so
called robotics or
artificial areas, again In that area,
there are many U.S.
company, ahead of on China.
But China started to see some local
born companies which had developed.
Developing it's own technology,
company like DGI.
Right?
You know,
definitely the number one
player in the drone space.
And so I think we'll probably
see some interesting dynamics,
even the Chinese company will
doing better than some of the U.S.
company addressing those major trends.
But you know just like
what we have seen before.
Every couple of years there's
new technology break through and
bringing new commercial opportunity.
But relatively speaking I
think China's opportunity
may be bigger when compared with U.S..
Because the so-called,
the efficiency in the tradition
industry is a world behind,
compared with U.S..
That's why e-commerce could do so
well in China compared with the US.
And same for.
So, while we're on the topic of
American companies in China.
China's a huge market.
Growing.
Second largest economy in the world.
And Sakuya China has actually also
been working with a lot of these
American companies.
You've investing in LinkedIn,
you're a strategic partner with Airbnb.
So for you, when did you have some
of these biggest opportunities,
especially challenges to American
companies entering China?
And what Sakuya's role in
helping navigate this?
>> If you look at global companies,
especially U.S. companies coming to China.
I'd say in the first 30 years,
40 years, when China opened door
>> Many U.S.
company has been very successful.
Because the technology is so advanced,
that when you're trying,
there's no competitions.
Like when GM come to China,
people love it.
Even though GM might not be the best
automobile company in the world.
Right?
And a lot of joint ventures get setup.
So, at that time, you know,
the key word in a joint venture is
use technology to gain market share.
Right.
[FOREIGN]
So whether it's European players or
American player, often times set
up their own subsidiaries or
set up a joint venture in China.
And they could do very well
against the competition.
Either against the private company,
or against the state enterprises.
But since has been really changed,
many sectors today,
the private companies in China and still
enterprise in China are very competitive.
They have learned,
they are developing their own ideas.
And they can really compete very
effectively with you, right?
When PNG goes to China,
when GM goes to China back 30 years ago.
They dominate certain space.
Today, they have to compete
fiercely with many local players.
So one of the ideas here is that,
if a U.S. company comes to China.
Just copy what they have in done in U.S.,
it may not be that effect to anymore.
So you have to have to change your model,
your product to cater to China's market.
Very unique business involvement.
Especially in the internet space.
Because internet, for internet, China and
U.S. start around the same time.
For some business model,
China even advance compared with U.S.
for some example today,
clearly much better than some of those
social network companies in China.
You can't say learn from Facebook or
copycat Facebook.
In fact, if you look at Facebook and
you know, many others,
some of those features are run
from Chinese companies.
So if a internet company in U.S.
want to go to China,
they have to think about whether
they have a edge there or not.
Secondly, they going to have to face
the competition from local companies,
many driven by very,
very strong entrepreneurs.
So how are you going to be successful?
One thing which we suggest, is to having
a very unique share holding structures.
You should introduce someone as
entrepreneur, as in your home country.
Someone not listen to the head office, but
someone able to based his product and
service around Chinese
unique business involvement.
And leverage the edge from head office.
That's how we did it on
the LinkedIn ventures and
that's sort of why I'll try very hard for
NBNB.
The product of LinkedIn and
NBMB are wonderful,
there's no question about it, but
there are some local competitors.
Their CEOs and
their farmers are very strong.
And you need to have a structure
where the guy who run
link in China has a direct
interest in running that business.
So, the management team need
to be compensated properly.
And not just compensated at a head office,
and I think that's probably the best
way for a U.S. company to compete,
and do well in China.
In fact, if a Chinese company
come to Silicon Valley,
they should do the same thing, right?
If they send someone from head office and
try to compete with local company here
in US, I don't think they have a chance.
But they have to find the best
talent in Silicon Valley and
give them enough economic interest,
let them run the show.
And then leverage the back end from China,
and
then you might have a chance
of competing locally.
It is the model moving
forward I propose for
both US company as well for
Chinese companies.
So that's how we actually
being LinkedIn to China and
that's how we bring NBNB China.
And I think this is probably a model
that we'll see if this fits for
many other US companies.
Even though, they have already very,
very successful here on US.
And as the business partner
what do we bring to a table is
that we helping to get the best team.
And also to put all
resources behind it and
to make sure that you have the right
partners for your efforts.
And actually it's very, it's not easy
to find such so called local CEOs.
Because he need to be very entrepreneur,
as I mentioned.
At the same time, he have to understand
how to working with a large organization.
Because you do want to
leverage your head office.
Some of the existing
technology infrastructures.
And someone who knows how to make
sure the respective department
within your head office can
work with you very closely.
So it's difficult to
find this type of talent.
It's a tough job.
And we have been trying very hard.
And so far, we have been quite
successful with Lincoln and
hopefully we can extend
it to other US companies.
>> Definitely want to
stay in airbnbs in China.
So now two questions from the audience.
We have Maria and Neve on either side.
Please raise your hand high if you
are interested in asking a question so
they can spot you.
You can also tweet to our #stanfordgss
if you have a question and
I think we'll start with
a question from Twitter.
>> Right, so thank you both for
such an inspirational discussion.
Now the first question from Twitter.
Many of us here aspire
to be entrepreneurs and
see China as a great market opportunity,
but
what are some of the unique challenges
that entrepreneurs face in China?
And how do you recommend we overcome them?
>> I think one of the most frequently
encountered challenges is competition.
It's actually interesting.
I'm always very puzzled and
I still do not have the perfect answer.
Here in the US, in Silicon Valley,
there's one business model.
Typically, no one either care to copy,
or no really need to copy.
You know you have Uber,
you have airbnb you
have LinkedIn, there's very few copycats.
In China,
as long as your business is doing well
you will definitely have copycats.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's a matter of how to compete more
successfully.
And that actually is putting pressure on
the leaders to innovate all the time,
right.
I remember when I was running C Trip.
One of the, my routine job is
come to Monday meeting and
discuss how our competitor was doing,
especially Eelung, right?
So one of the Monday discussion
items is spending 30 minutes,
and discuss what Eelung have
launched in the last one week.
And indeed, I have to say many of those
are copied, what set you've been doing.
Some are very detailed, like marketing,
plans, like sending carts at the airport
when we do that they get back.
So, okay to do right,
you just have to innovate all the time
to make sure you stay ahead of the game.
And it's a rarity, and
people have to face.
Many business models you can not IP it,
and you just have to raise more money.
You just have to innovate all the time.
And you just have to differentiate
yourself well enough and
that differentiation sometimes
coming down through very details.
When we look at Citribus and eLong,
at that time we are around
two times bigger than eLong.
And one would differentiate we
have is through call center.
We provided better services.
That's actually become a big edge.
And if you come down to
merchant relationship,
when we establish certain relationship
with a hotel group, they follow.
That relationship,
it's difficult to exclusive deals.
But only thing which has been
done well in differential sale
is a better customer services.
And so you can call that small details but
that small detail bring very big change.
Bring very big gap of four
Citrum against eLong.
And so for China, if you want to get into
those competitive space, you have to.
Be prepared and to innovate all the times.
And the other thing that I want to
probably point out is that it's
difficult to retain
talents in Silicon Valley,
because people are going
to strike out on their own.
It's even more difficult to do so
in China.
If you're looking at a turn over rate
at a major Internet companies in China,
it's actually higher,
a lot higher compare with US companies.
Many company feel like you know.
Sorry, many senior executive feel like,
you know to do startup today.
You know, the environment's so good.
There's so many people, so
much money, a chase after them.
And they,
especially in the mobile Internet space,
the entry barrier to start up
something is very, is lower.
So, we do see people willing to consider,
do something on his own.
Instead of staying with a large company.
And so I think that's a challenge,
that how to retain people.
And obviously compensation is one way,
ESOP, etc.
But also to build a very strong culture to
make sure that your top people could stay.
>> Thank you for sharing with us.
I'm Talbe, MBA 1.
So I'm really curious to see how you can
evaluate a company with a trend that is
kind of uncertain.
So earlier you mentioned that
big data is one of the trends.
And within big data there's going to
be a lot of different sectors.
>> Yeah.
>> Medicine, education, you name it.
Can you maybe walk through us,
share some insights on how you
would actually have quantifiable
metrics within those big data
sectors to determine which one
would be potentially successful?
>> I think there's a few common,
sort of check in point we will look at
when we're looking at any start-up.
This is the same, whether it's
customer internet or with a price.
One is obviously,
the background of the team,
whether it actually fits for
that type of entrepreneurship.
For example, if it's e-commerce,
I will be very eager to know whether
he has a consumer retail experience.
Whether he had supply chain experience.
But for such enterprises, I will look
to see if he has the relevant software
experience or
enterprise experience before.
Secondly, I will also look at market size.
That's actually very very important,
if you look at e-commerce area,
the reason why JD become one of
the top internet companies in China,
because they address the most
important area at the very beginning.
The three C's, the consumer,
the [INAUDIBLE] electronics.
If you start from something else.
For example you found
some books they want.
That you may not get as a kid as you grow.
So the total [INAUDIBLE]
market always something
very important especially in
the first one to two years.
You can always expand from your core
areas after you've become successful.
So in the southern parts of the area,
you have to start from some verticals.
And the question is,
whether that vertical is big enough for
you to become a very substantial
leader and you can expand from that.
Beyond these two point,
the other very important I think
area to look after is
whether the time is right.
Because enterprises demand
in China is clearly there.
But people have priorities for
particular corporates, they look at it.
How much money I will spend
on any different software?
And what are the key sort of
area I want put money this year
against a year later or two year later?
So for any type of software
you should look at those
area which corporate are having
the most pain in increasing efficiency.
We look at securities, we look at storage,
we look at performance areas,
we look at HRIS.
Some of those areas in which clearly
with dividing labor costs you
have to address in those issues.
And I think that's probably an important
point for venture capitalists,
as well as for entrepreneur who wants
to start a business in that sector.
>> Thank you, Mr for your speeches,
it's very inspiring.
So my question is about people.
When you were about to start
how did you find your partners?
Because without good partners is
impossible for startups is successful.
And the same as here, like, now if we
want to build up a startup in china,
what's the most effective way
to find the perfect partners?
Thank you.
>> It's difficult to find
perfect partners, but
as long as you find good partners,
that's okay.
When I look at many startups,
when they walked into our conference
room to present, to be honest,
most of the team at the so
called anxious stage or serious stage
to not have a complete team but
you need to have some co-team member and
addressing the major needs.
In base we have myself and James and
Chichi frankly is a little crowded team.
We have guy already have a lot of
experience in different business
segment but even with that three
people we just have to find Famine.
Well who has worked at the travel
industry for many years.
Because we do realize online
travel is about internet,
but at the same time it's about travel.
So we want someone who understand
the travel industry a lot.
About how to build
a relationship with hotels?
How to position ourselves against all
the other traditional travel agencies?
So these are very interesting
questions that you have to address and
you find someone who can complement your
skill set and to addressing those issues.
And if you're going to have a so-called
core team at first, not a complete team,
then try to find what are the most
critical component of your starter
like e-commerce then you have to better
have someone who understand supply chain.
If you do not have someone experienced
in that segment you don't even
have the business taking off but
maybe someone who do a better job
doing online marketing come second.
It's still very important, but
it's not the most critical at the day one.
So I think you just have to go
along with your business ramp-up
to find that team gradually.
Day one to find a complete
team is always challenge.
>> I think we have time for
one last question from the audience.
>> Hi Neil, thanks for your time.
My question is which is a bigger bubble?
China or Silicon Valley?
>> [LAUGH]
>> I want to be more,
I actually want to be more specific.
So here's a though experiment.
If Uber raises another round right now,
and if the latest
round investors are guaranteed a three
times return, would you be an investor?
Thanks.
>> I don't want to comment
specifically on the Uber case, but
I don't see a so-called big bubble there,
because at
the end of the day you ask yourself,
are those startups really creating values?
If they do create values, and
most of the startup companies are creating
values, I'm not particularly worried.
Valuation, there's always ups and downs.
If you look at a popular market,
there's always ups and downs anyway.
And so I would not particularly
worry about valuation itself.
Because the market itself will adjust.
The venture capitalist,
in general, I'm not stupid enough
to pay a premium consistently.
They might pay premium for a short period
of time, but they will adjust themselves.
And when you look at the so-called bubble,
most of the companies
are just creating a lot of
so-called users without providing value
to users that's something which I worry.
But if you look at UBER and ABNB, right?
I mean clearly these are two
of the startup companies
which become very successful.
They do create a lot of values, right?
I mean UBER clearly has
provide the most efficiency,
the most efficient
transportation systems for
all the people around the world and
ABNB has clearly new demands.
And something which the hotel industry
has never even thought about.
So I think these are either creating new
demand or increase efficiency big time.
Ultimately, the value will be
created by those companies.
I'm not particularly worried that if
there is any so called in a bubble
because the company my ahead of
itself a little bit for variation.
If you look at China back in 1999,
where there's a bunch of
companies like [INAUDIBLE]
like [INAUDIBLE], it's difficult to
comment on the variation at each stage.
But what is important is that they
do bring value to the companies,
to the whole economy.
What I would be very worried about, is,
when those companies
are [INAUDIBLE] a very thin value.
I want to raise, use one examples.
Back in 2001 and 2002, there's a bunch
of companies called SP company in China.
I don't know if you guys still remember.
Maybe some of you are not
living in China at the time.
They are providing either linked homes or
pictures for the China Mobile,
China Unicom etc.
And most of the companies have died or
have been sold.
And sold itself is not issue,
issue is when the company is sold it,
the company almost disappear.
It's not like a YouTube or Instagram.
They're there in
the proper valid to users.
Why does a company disappear?
At one point, they are very,
very profitable.
Because they charge you
the fees through China Mobile and
China Unicom.
And it can be very profitable,
because the value created is just so thin.
People do not need that middle man.
China Mobile can do it
themselves after they fill out.
So, that's why it was [INAUDIBLE],
that's the real bubble.
If you talk about the bubble in
the last ten, 15, years in China.
Those SP company as a whole is a bubble,
and if we can avoid
that I think they know that almost
startup environment is really healthy.
>> Great, well, before we end Neil,
one last question.
So as a really successful
entrepreneur yourself,
and now being the entrepreneur
behind entrepreneurs.
What advice would you have for aspiring
entrepreneurs here in the audience
as they look to build something new?
>> I think you have to go with your heart.
[LAUGH] It's difficult to
make a perfect choice.
And, at least in my case, is that
each time when I make a choice I say,
one, whether this go with a big trend.
Secondly, and probably more important,
which is something you really like to do?
When I was working at Deutsche Bank, and
in the last sort of a year or so in 1999.
I really, really was excited by
the Internet development in China.
I really want to do something.
If I'm not going to do Sea Trip,
I would do something else.
But Sea Trip itself fits me
well because I love travelling.
At the same time, I think the Internet
can change people's life in China.
So you have to really love what you do,
otherwise it's going to
be difficult to sustain.
If you just think this
is just a big trend, but
there's something which you don't like or
you don't know whether you like it or not.
Then if you work there for
like 6 months and 12 months,
you'll probably feel like, oh,
I want to jump to the next trend.
I do notice there's some
entrepreneur like that.
We have this Monday meeting and
then when some entrepreneur
come to visit and ask him, so
why you want to do this entrepreneurship?
Oh, B to B is hot or big data is hot.
But the question fundamental is, do you
think you are the best fit for this?
And do you really have passion for that?
And that's a question
you should ask yourself.
No matter what other people's interest,
you should find your interest and
follow your heart, and find the stuff
you are passionate about it and do it.
>> All right, thank you so much, Neil.
Real pleasure having you here today.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]